so much we still don't know about
coronavirus and what comes next the
health secretary here today to answer
some of the thousands of questions
submitted by Sky News viewers and the
first one about this man professor Neil
Ferguson who was until last night a key
adviser to the government forced to
resign after breaking the lockdown rules
he helped design the social distancing
rules are there for everyone and they're
incredibly important and they're deadly
serious should he be prosecuted well
that you can imagine what my views are
but that is absolutely imagination it's
a matter for the police
other questions people want answering
when might they go back to work be
reunited with family send their kids
back to school it's tempting to give
concrete answers but the problem is of
course I do and I think and what that
I'm not you know dodging the question
I'm answering really directly we don't
know questions not just from the public
but from MPs to the prime minister out
of number 10 to the Commons for his
first appearance there in six weeks it
is good to be back even though I've been
away for longer than I had intended and
during his absence the UK's death toll
has climbed it's a devastating haze he
said that many people were looking at
the apparent success of the government's
approach but yesterday we learned
tragically that at least twenty nine
thousand four hundred twenty seven
people in the UK have now lost their
lives to this dreadful virus that's now
the highest number in Europe it's the
second highest in the world that's not
success I don't think that international
comparisons and the data is is yet there
to draw the conclusions that we want the
argument that international comparisons
can't really be made when the
government's been using slides like this
for weeks to do international comparison
it just really doesn't hold water the UK
was slow in to lock down slow on testing
slow on tracing and slow on the supply
of protective equipment people want to
know how we get out of lockdown labour
pushing too
here the plan will the Primus to give
that reassurance by setting out his plan
as he says he will or will he come to
this house or Monday to present that
plan we want if we possibly can to get
going with some of these measures on
Monday I think it will be a good thing
mr. speaker if if people had an idea of
what's coming the Prime Minister wants
to tweak the lock down as early as
Monday well what might that look like a
senior minister tells me that could mean
reopening smaller shops and outdoor
workplaces but they are still looking at
the data the watchword in all of this is
caution stamping on the accelerator just
too dangerous think of this more as
slowly lifting your foot off the brake
the PM wants to lift the lockdown
nationally but devising a road map to
navigate a disease you still don't fully
understand is difficult the government
desperate to avoid a second peak but
expect bumps along the road beth Rigby
Sky News Westminster